all right it's time for drew's news your
news zen garden where we slowly rake the
sands of the good news
and with me at the desk is
a man who helps me keep calm and carry
on every day ross matthew hi everybody
um
okay first up i don't know about you but
i love seeing inside people's homes
totally i am a real creeper creature and
especially when it comes to design i
mean that is my happy place so
architectural digest does these home
tours with people and buzzfeed reports
that actress ashley tisdale just did one
and miss tisdale caused a real tisdale
tizzy over this moment so here's the
moment this is what got everybody's
panties in everybody's talking about it
these bookshelves i have to be honest
were not actually did not have books in
it like a couple days ago um i had my
husband go to a bookstore and i was like
you need to get 400 bucks
so people had a field day on twitter
ashley took it in stride she tweeted
back that some of the books were in fact
hers and she only did what any interior
designer would have done
and but people got like angry about this
yeah
i know and i'm not gonna read ashley
tisdale for filth just like she didn't
read any of those books okay
no judgment to you and you know what i
think i have a lot of books in my house
i haven't read any of them my fiancee
wellington he's read them all i'm like
can you tell me about them or just tell
me when they make it into a movie right
because i don't have time are you
reading all the books in your house um i
mean miss tisdale took the words out of
my mouth i was literally going to go
into interior design before this show
came i i l i love interior design i
study it
this is what an interior designer would
do this happens in magazines and
things all the time how dare people rip
this girl apart for something so asinine
like preach drew barrymore priests
i miss tisdale i'm with you i've got
your back and thank you for contributing
to a bookstore and putting money in
their coffers which they need
you're just doing the same thing
that other people do
and you don't need to be ripped for it
and everyone who ripped her get a life i
can't handle this oh okay he's so mad
drew has spoken everyone you hear that i
thought you're back ashley
yeah you did all right next up i have a
question for you drew okay do you wear
shoes in your house
yeah i do i knew you did
the shoe inside the house debate is not
news but now the blog scary mommy
reports scientists have officially
weighed in and they say
don't you dare walk around your house in
your dirty filthy shoes because they are
gross and scientists say your disgusting
shoes are responsible for one third of
the filth in your home yeah they track
in bacteria microorganism toxins
chemicals
doggy doo doo all that stuff uh gets on
your floor and floats into the air
particles and so you are literally
breathing in your dirty shoe dirt drew
are you gonna change
no
i don't know again this kind of goes
into like the acai bowls and the
microbes and the whole thing i'm just
like you know what
germs help build up immunity i love like
when i'm in a dirty public bathroom and
i'm standing there and i think i know
you'll be on my bedroom carpet later
yeah but like i don't care by the way
you know what the dirtiest thing is
according to a lot of studies what money
really yes
that is worse than toilet um
you know handles really well yeah guess
what everyone you can bring your money
in my house but leave your shoes on the
porch okay
not happening it's coming from
everywhere
it's coming from everywhere
it's hard
i i'm not uptight about stuff like that
like i'm more offended that people like
ripped this girl for buying books you
know that i'm like really white why in
this tender world right now do you have
to make someone feel bad for something
like that and then just wear the shoes i
don't know
i don't know i'm very positive but this
is the kind of stuff where i'm just like
no leave your shoes on and leave ashley
tisdale alone understood everyone got it
wait i would love
to those are the rules
i'd love to know
how many people here because it is
really a thing and it's like there are
cultural things there are people who
really are passionate about cleanliness
how many people here do take their shoes
off at their house
yeah a lot of people kyle yes kyle
may i ask you why
and i'd like to learn from you because
i'm i am not close-minded about this
i just am too lazy i think that's my
problem
well it's a combination of two things
okay one
the germs as ross said
and the other is we vacation in hawaii
and there's tradition everyone takes
their shoes off so we bring that
tradition back to new york well that's
cute thank you oh i went to hawaii once
and got laid i'd like to bring that
tradition
thank you
[Music]